-Milo, you've acted
in all sorts of roles,
and that means you're in touch
with so many emotions,
but I wanted to see
just how emotional we can get.
It's time for
an Emotional Interview.
Here we go.
-♪ Emotional interview ♪
-Now, here's how it works.
We're gonna have a normal
conversation with each other,
except every so often we're
gonna hear this ding sound.
[ Ding ]
And when we hear that,
we'll be given an emotion
or situation that we have to
act out as we keep talking.
And you'll see it on the screen.
You'll see it
on your Zoom screen.
Does that sound good?
-Yeah. Great.
-Okay. Good.
-Sounds great.
-All right.
So, the game's kind of starting.
So, now, when the --
when the pandemic ends,
do you have any plans
for vacation?
-[ Ding ]
-Do you have --
-Oh, my God!
I'm gonna go everywhere!
-Yeah! No! Me too, dude!
Oh, no, no, no!
No, no. Me, me!
-I'm gonna drive.
I'm gonna fly.
-I'm gonna fly. No.
I'm gonna drive. No. Yeah.
That's right, yo!
I love flying! I love driving!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah!
-Wait, wait, wait, wait!
Let's go together!
-Let's do it, dude!
We've got to!
-[ Ding ]
-Bro!
-Uh...
-So, really, it's like --
Sometimes I'm in boxers.
Sometimes I'm in briefs.
But really, like,
at other times,
it's just, you know --
There's -- There's nothing.
I'm not wearing anything.
But look. Long story short.
Long story short.
-Yeah. Yeah, I know --
-You wear what you need
in the moment...
-You do.
-...because --
In those moments, sometimes --
-I used to wear --
My roommate who is --
Well, he -- Long story short,
he's not my roommate anymore.
Uh, but --
-Wait. What happened?
'Cause you guys were, like --
You guys were really close
friends, right?
You'd known each other
since you were in ki--
I mean, it's a long story
made incredibly short for TV.
-[ Laughter ]
-[ Ding ]
-"Made incredibly short."
I understand.
Now, walk me through it again.
On TV, what that's like
to tell a short story, again.
-Yes, sir. Yes, sir.
So -- So, sir, if you have
your television on...
-Yeah. No, no, no.
I hear you. I hear you.
-And it's set it to channel 4.
-I hear you. And I understand.
I understand. No. I totally --
-I'm sorry. I'm sorry.
Would you take a survey
at the end of this...?
[ Ding ]
Would you let people know
if I'm doing a good job?
'Cause when I think --
[ Coughs ]
-I'll take a survey.
I'll take a survey
just like I took the shrimp
that I just took off my --
[Muffled] There was a platter
of shrimp -- of shrimp.
-[Muffled]
Do you have an EpiPen?
-There was a platter of shrimp.
There was a platter of shrimp
that I saw.
And there was a survey.
But it was a platter of shrimp.
And I haven't had a shrimp.
No! No!
-[ Ding ]
-[Normal voice] Well, anyway,
we can talk about this tomorrow.
And, uh -- It's a good --
Yeah. And thank you so much.
And, you know, I think we --
-[Normal voice] Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It was -- It was great.
I mean, listen. I'm always --
I'm so happy to be here.
I'll be here next time.
It was great seeing you.
-Uh-huh. Yeah.
-Take care.
-Oh, that's totally interesting.
And that's good.
Where's "leave meeting"?
Uh, yeah.
[ Dinging ]
I would never do that.
That's how you do it!
That's how you get that statue!
That's my man right here!
An emotional interview
with Milo Ventimiglia.
"This Is Us" airs Tuesdays
at 9:00 pm on NBC.